hey what's up my name's Samuel leaves
I'm a property investor and in this
video I'm gonna be giving you an
explainer answer to the property
investment strategy Lease Option
agreements what is a lease option
agreement and should you be buying
properties using the exaction agreement
all I figured out how to do Lease Option
agreements when I was a teenager because
I didn't have any money and what a lease
option agreement is it's just when you
buy a house now but you pay for it later
that's effectively what a lease option
agreement is now for me as a teenager I
love the idea of that because I was
desperate to get my foot on the property
ladder
I knew that properties were gonna go up
in value I really wanted to get the keys
and be like I own that but I didn't have
any money so I learned this strategy
lease option agreement now here's how it
works
lease option agreement you set a price
today so let me give you an example of a
car if you're buying a car let's say you
say that car's ten thousand pounds
that's the value of the car and you say
I'll buy it for ten thousand pounds I'll
put nothing down today and then I'll buy
it in five years and in five years I'll
pay the ten thousand pounds now you can
kind of do things like that but I
personally don't think that's smart
because if you buy a car now and you say
the values ten thousand or buy in five
years what always happens is in five
years what has happened to the car well
the car has gone down in value so even
though you get to drive around this car
right now and it's like isn't it awesome
I've got this car I paid no money for it
really
that's almost immediate gratification
and it's not smart because in five years
you're going to suffer because you're
going to buy this car and suddenly
you're gonna have to cash out 10 grams
but the cars probably only worth five
thousand pounds because car is a
depreciating thing it's a liability
second reason why it wouldn't be very
smart with a car is because last time I
checked cars didn't give you any rent
cars don't give you any money so in that
five years how are you going to get the
money to pay for the car if you can't
afford it now how you're gonna be able
to afford it in five years time so the
whole idea of buying something now I'm
paying for it later generally is
probably not that smart you buy a
holiday now you go to pay for it later
the holidays finished and you've still
got the debt however we
a property a lease option agreement
number one you don't have to buy the
property at the end of the five years so
you can with a lease option agreement at
the end of the five years you can walk
away and hand the keys back and pay
nothing now that's why it's called lease
option and not lease obligation however
the seller has to let you exercise your
option so it's kind of like a having
your cake and eat it so that's the first
great thing about doing lease option
agreements within residential property
imagine if you drove a car around for
five years and you hadn't paid a penny
then you went now change my mind and
you're handed it back that'll be amazing
well that's what you can do with
properties however on top of that
properties tend to go up in value not
down so if you agree to buy a property
now for a hundred thousand pounds and
then in five years time or seven years
time however long you agree this period
over in seven years time what happens if
the house is worth 150 or 200 thousand
pounds and this is something that's
happened to me many many times well what
happens is suddenly you've got yourself
an absolute bargain of a property deal
and you've had five years or seven years
to save up for that properties that's
the second amazing thing about lease
option agreements and the third amazing
thing about these option agreements are
if you are buying the property now but
paying for it later
you get the keys now but you've not paid
anything what are you going to do with
that property you're going to rent it
out so you're going to start benefiting
from monthly cash flow now you might be
thinking now Samuel sounds good in fact
Samuel it almost sounds a little bit too
good and if something sounds too good to
be true it usually is listen in most of
my videos when I talk about property
investment strategies I talk about the
good I talk about the bad and there's
often a lot of bad with lease option
agreements honestly there's very little
bad the only bad thing is is actually
finding a seller that's up willing to
pass your prop let you have it on a
lease option agreement you don't come
across those types of sellers every hour
or every day you've got to work to find
those sellers so and also of lease
option agreements just because you don't
pay anything now
going to put this out as a disclaimer
you do have to pay the legal fees so
you're gonna have to pay a solicitor to
draw up the contracts which will cost
maybe around a thousand pounds also you
will need to pay a one pound option fee
in order to make the contracts legal so
there's gonna be a little bit of money
but with that you have a property and
you rent it out and you get the cash
flow from the rent and you're
benefitting from the capital
appreciation so if the only negative is
finding the sellers the question is are
there any sellers that would do this and
you might be again thinking like
thinking right now no one would do that
no one would pass their house on to me
on a lease option agreement where I
could buy it now and pay for it later
who would do that in their right mind
let me tell you exactly who will do this
because there are people doing it I've
secured many Lease Option agreements my
students have secured many Lease Option
agreements and the reason the way you to
do it is you need to find sellers who
either don't need or can't get the money
now so if someone's selling their house
because they need them money now you buy
it they use that money to buy another
house to live in that's not going to
work for a lease option agreement but if
you find people are selling their houses
who've inherited their house and they're
like oh I've got this house I don't know
what to do with it I don't live near it
what you know they don't need the money
if they sell it they're just gonna use
the money to put in the back and just
have it in savings for those types of
people that are struggling to sell a
lease option agreement can be perfect
because you're taking the property off
of their hands you're green to buy it
down the line and what you normally do
the lease option agreement is you pay a
small monthly fee second type of people
are people in negative equity so if
you've got a property where your
mortgage is really high and the value of
your house is lower than the mortgage
outstanding and by the way that's
happening more than ever right now in
2020 because of Corona and the epidemic
and what's going on property prices are
dipping which is leaving people with a
higher mortgage than the value of their
house so those types of people that want
to sell they can't sell and even if they
did sell and someone paid them the the
asking price all they do with that money
is they'd use it to pay off the mortgage
those are the types of
people where their house to them that
even want it they've got no equity in it
where you can secure a buy now pay later
lease option agreement and when you can
find those people you can then begin to
build your portfolio using very very
very little money now if you want to
learn more about this strategy of lease
option agreements I do sometimes run
free webinars where I give advanced
training on this strategy and go through
exactly how to find these types of
sellers in the description on this video
you can click the link and you can leave
your details and I will let you know
you'll be the first to know when I'm
running one of these webinars if you've
got questions about lease option
agreement comment them below and I'll do
my best to answer I might do a follow-up
video if you want to learn more
strategies check out the rest of my
channel if you enjoyed this video and
open your mind that it made you think
why not share it with a friend share it
with somebody else smash the like button
and don't forget to subscribe
turn on a notification bell so you never
miss a property investment video again
thanks so much for watching I'll see you
next time